allora per chi non lo dovesse sapere il
dottor lino caserta gestisce un centro
di medicina solidale
quando l'ho incontrato la prima volta la
cosa che mi ha stupito è arrivata alla
fine è il fatto è che lui mi ha detto
questo non è un centro di medicina per
persone diciamo bisognose questo è un
polo di eccellenza ed effettivamente io
quando ho visto quella roba non me ne
ero accorto perché avevo solo parlato
con lui ed effettivamente quella
eccellenza pura gratuita ma pura e
quindi vi dico questa cosa come è stata
possibile come come l'avete messa su in
piedi ma non tanto da un punto di vista
economico un solo punto di vista mentale
c'è come si arriva all'eccellenza in una
maniera del genere l'idea e passione per
poi incontrare tanti amici di incontro
ritornano gli incontri poi incontrare
altri amici tanti collaboratori riescono
a loro volta danno appassionarsi a
condividere il progetto ea portarla
anche eccellenza cioè non luogo diverso
insomma quando si parla di buche se
pensavo a un ambulatorio gratuito
la gente indigente mentre insomma in
pelle cosa raffazzonata insomma qualcosa
si visita qualcosa insomma si cerca di
dare qualcosa noi non abbiamo mai
pensato così insomma noi pensiamo che
ogni aspetto del rapporto con il
paziente in un cittadino abbia bisogno
di cura a partire dall'approccio
iniziale la comunicazione e poi il
momento clou quella della natura quella
che tendiamo della diagnosi e della
terapia e il centro è un certo
accogliente accogliente già come come
organizzazione proprio come architettura
come
come arredamento ma questo non parte del
linguaggio no si entra in un posto in
cui c'è cura e già questo fa capire che
probabilmente si riceverà della cura
così come lo intendiamo in maniera più
nobile non nel senso tecnico della
parola e non ci teniamo a questo non
solo per l'aspetto della comunicazione
perché pensiamo che comunque l'indigente
comunque di kg nel momento di difficoltà
abbia diritto alla bellezza del rapporto
e alla bellezza del nuovo perché
probabilmente in quei momenti in quei
momenti di sofferenza sono in questi
momenti magari possono incontrare questa
bellezza e poi ritornano comunque
situazioni in cui la bellezza la
incontro in maniera per morto o più
raramente mi rimproverano ci
rimproverano di aver fatto un posto dove
vengono anche persone ricche
io credo che sia un motivo di successo
non abbiamo creato un posto per poveri
avremmo creato altrimenti se venissero
sono poveri
un luogo che per esempio nei luoghi che
negli stati uniti sono stati aboliti e
quarantenni che è proprio cioè scusami
se ti interrompo perché proprio su
questo punto perché ho una delle unioni
prossimo comandi quindi per favore i
momenti cipani per chiarimenti sono
finito questo pazzo che tra le cose che
ti stupiscono appena di vini
al centro ci sono gli articoli della
costituzione che può interpretare a
volte vanno semplicemente letti e capiti
altre volte cioè se io vado a leggere
questo sgabello e grosso non c'è niente
da interpretare in altri in altri luoghi
del mondo e ad esempio gli stati uniti
magari sotto 1.000 punti di vista molto
più avanzati di noi sono ancora alla
fase 1 o forse la cosa in meno uno che è
quella del chiedersi se il principio per
cui la salute sia un diritto non lo so
come dire non debba essere inarrivabile
sono ancora in quella fase
se lo chiedono lo è non lo è invece noi
ci siamo arrivati tanto tanto tanto
tempo fa a dire ragazzi la salute della
prima cosa è veramente come come le
nonne no alla salute alla prima cosa ci
siamo arrivati però poi effettivamente
nel corso degli anni abbiamo un po
dimenticata l'abbiamo teso dimenticare
po il vostro centro non lo avete fatto
quindi se questa diciamo dinamica anche
relativa alla costituzione che ha
ispirato in qualche modo si è ispirata
soprattutto nei momenti nel momento in
cui abbiamo capito che molti diritti che
ero risultato di conquiste che avevano
visto impegnati anche in maniera cruenta
insomma artigiani quella costituzione è
stata scritta con il sangue di tanti
ragazzi che ci hanno trasmesso questo
dono
questo insieme di regole apparentemente
si sente in realtà dietro ogni anno più
di ogni parola degli oltre ogni frase
dietro ogni articolo il principio c'è
inizia non sapere filosofico che i mezzi
ecco come amante qui ci siamo messi ci
siamo accorti e questo va dai 10 per
questi diritti cominciavano ad essere in
qualche modo messo in discussione e
quindi traditi quei principi che avevano
che l'avevano ispirati per ci siamo
detti in bocca stile marini piuttosto
che declamare come si fa a ormai nove
parlare semplicemente richiedere il
cambiamento dobbiamo rimboccarci le
maniche come dobbiamo cominciare a
anzitutto frenare questo mi da da st
questa deriva troppo logica per cui
insomma questi vero incide questi
diritti vengono messe in discussione e
poi dobbiamo cominciare soprattutto
dalle nostre adatti come c'era
costruircelo questi diritti
dobbiamo cominciare a questo del 5 un
mondo diverso
un altro mondo diciamo un altro mondo è
possibile
cominciamo a costruirlo può farlo
chiamato un sacco dargli ragione pratica
noce ricordando un po country patetica
il modo di rapportarci di stare insieme
vivo in questo caso dove la ragione
pratica è sì un etica magari e uova però
qualcosa che ci impegni praticamente per
mettersi a lavorare a sporcarsi le mani
dedicare del tempo dedicarsi sotto
questo punto di vista è importante il
fatto che poi continuate a fare ricerca
ed è una ricerca un po strana
effettivamente perché tu vai in giro per
la per la città o comunque per le città
e ti metti proprio a dispo no a
disposizione a disposizione del mero
sapere e per farlo però hai bisogno di
tanto non solo di tanto tempo ma bisogna
anche di tantissima collaborazione
persone realmente fare questo non so se
abbia comprato delle difficoltà se poi
nel corso del tempo
l'aver rinunciato
non so se avete rinunciato
effettivamente però siete diventati
diciamo più probabilmente più impegnati
sul lato medico secondi e su quello
della ricerca forse forse no o se questa
cosa lo avete dovuto affrontare un
determinato tipo mobile
in realtà quella è stata soprattutto la
prima fase della nascita nella villa
miologia lo spiega in poche parole è
quella disciplina delle medicine che si
occupa delle cause e della distribuzione
delle malattie per proprio perché si
occupa di questo deve uscire fuori nel
territorio no devo andare a studiare
tutta la popolazione segue l'ammalata
questo ci ha impegnato soprattutto i
primi dieci anni dal 2001 dopo questi
abbonati
al 2010 li abbiamo una buona serie di
tadic annualmente importante perché
abbiamo fatto in collaborazione con
istituti di ricerca nazionali ad esempio
l'istituto di sanità ma anche
internazionali per il college o
nell'ambito del corso è stato promosso
dall'università cinese e allora questi
dati che sono la sono tantissime abbiamo
come ha detto i dieci anni ancora pochi
uno delle dita con l'epidemia luce
perché l'epidemiologia perché così forse
un po riduttivo quando noi parliamo di
vicina solidale e presentiamo questo
progetto pensare che tutto questo si
esaurisca in una proposta
nell'ambulatorio grave gratuito per chi
non sa ma abbiamo detto anche la carta
di quella classe media che si impoverita
e anche per qualche riccone nera perché
vuole farsi visitare
non professionista particolare in realtà
la medicina solidale a napoli dove
insegna solidale fa parte di una mostra
molto più alte che noi abbiamo stiamo
cominciando definire che è quello della
medicina integrale c'è proprio nel senso
dell'ecologia integrale di francesco
veloce scuriscono sai baba cioè la
medicina non può più occupare
esclusivamente l'ambito è destinata
inevitabilmente al fallimento la
medicina intesa come impegno in ambito
clinico e quindi sapere
superspecializzato continua
semplicemente a produrre delle novità
dei farmaci nelle nuove tecnologie di
cui usufruiscono solo una piccola parte
della popolazione non solo non pensiamo
sole telescopi ricominciamo a pensare
anche all'italia che in italia ci sono
quasi 10 milioni di italiani che non
possono curarsi e non possono usufruire
di queste tecnologie qua in calabria in
modo particolare
e allora questa medicina deve uscire
dallo stabile deve ritornare ad essere
quella medicina sociale del 1800 1850
della medicina di mirko
che va a curare che va a capire quali
sono tutte le cause e colleghi de
miologia i determinanti di salute e il
medico in questa medicina integrale deve
ritornare ad assolvere al ruolo che
avevo un tempo c'è quello di naturale
avvocato dei poveri cioè deve impegnarsi
a tre affinché non solo nell'atto
tecnico curare il paziente ma impegnarsi
perché si determinino quelle condizioni
economiche culturali ambientali perché
la salute e il benessere venga
salvaguardato
guardate noi siamo in mano il paradigma
che privilegia l'infermità questo
paradigma che funzionale a determinati
interessi di potere curare all'infermità
significa produrre neanche farmaci
produrre gatti device produrre tante
tante apparecchiature mediche e molto
sofisticate per la voce un bilancio di
una regione come la calabria per il 75
per cento è impegnata nell'acquisto di
tutte queste cose
gran parte di queste ricchezze si
accumulano in questi ambiti commerciali
che producono farmaci device eccetera
in questi anni di crisi chi ha
guadagnato solamente sono state lenti
sia farmaci deve cominciare a spostare
allora questo paradigma dalla cura
dell'infermità alla cura delle
condizioni che determinano invece da
malattie cioè la prevenzione alla
salvaguardia della salute significa
cominciare a spostare risorse agli
investimenti verso altri settori non
meno importanti nella scelta significa
soprattutto investire in cultura
se investiamo in cottura noi avremo dei
cittadini più consapevoli che star
avranno gestirsi meglio e quindi
sapranno gestire più criticamente la
propria condizione di salute significa
gestite investire in ambiente e
investire in ambiente di creare le
condizioni perché ci sia un ambiente più
sano
non più un più sano insomma
non più neanche quella una logica di
atto antropocentrismo per cui è l'uomo
che decide quello che va fatto
sull'ambiente ma stiamo coniando questo
concetto dell'impatto di benessere cioè
qualsiasi cosa si va a realizzare nel
nostro ambiente deve far conto con il
benessere non solo nostro ma con il
benessere dell'ambiente
quindi la medicina integrare la medicina
solidale significa tutto questo è una
proposta non si esaurisce semplicemente
nell'ambulatorio unici ma solitario
nell'attività di ricerca di venire lo
cederemo prevalenza soprattutto nella
protezione di questo paradigma minos
questo nostro nuovo paradigma è un
paradigma soprattutto centrato sulla
prevenzione e sulla salvaguardia della
salute
guardate bene questa è l'unica strada
che noi abbiamo a disposizione perché
altrimenti il nostro sistema così come
lo conosciamo
cioè fondato sulla sulla solidarietà
inevitabilmente costretto a fallire
perché certamente tutti quanti stiamo
invecchiando
arriviamo stiamo prevedendo sempre più
gli anziani rispetto ai giovani le
tecnologie stanno costano sempre di più
i mac
i farmaci boscono sempre di più è la
malattia cronica degenerativa si sta
sempre di più allargando per le malattie
soprattutto dimenticate per l'obesità i
problemi di bilancio che oggi alla
calabria fra qualche anno li avrà anche
la lombardia l'emilia romagna se noi non
cominciamo a pensare ai termini di
prevenzione e salvaguardia che sono
quelle condizioni che consentiranno al
sistema di risparmiare tantissimo in
termini poi di cura delle qualità del
cyber se noi oggi investiamo in
prevenzione
fra i dieci anni non sto parlando fra 40
anni di minuto io do molto ma molto ma
molto breve noi realizzeremo
dell'economia e tre volte superiori al
all'investimento iniziale tutta questa
economia consentirà al sistema di
mantenersi di mantenersi in maniera
stabile e consentirà comico di
realizzare dei risparmi che potrebbe
essere investito in cultura un ambiente
il lavoro sicurezza trasporti eccetera
eccetera
ultimissima domanda ci possiamo prendere
un voto in più visto il format mi ha
detto una una cosa tra le altre cose
l'amico si dimentica che il tuo amico
nemico non si dimentica
al di là della medicina in breve in modo
breve come si dorme cosi cosi insito
materia perché voglio dire
realtà capisci che stai toccando degli
interessi no e quindi questo ti rende
sereno civile che sta facendo il tuo
problema
tutti questi interessi fa abbiamo
parlato di vita che si più grossi poi ci
sono interessi molto più miserabili sono
molto più i mestieri se tocchi queste
interessi e sai che queste interessi e
comunque un interesse privato c'è un
interesse mafioso sai che sei
sicuramente schierato con gran parte
della gente per bene questo tipo ha
detto i due bellissimi
grazie
[Applauso]